hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
in diesem Video erfährst du wie du mit
deinem big createck umgehst wenn du ihn
bestellt hast und er bei dir zu Hause
ankommt wie den auspackst aufbaust in
anzündest und am Ende auch noch reinigst
insgesamt gibt es sieben verschiedene
big Creed Größen und es wie beim
Autokauf für jeden ist was anderes mit
dabei und für jeden gibt es die passende
Größe ich zeige euch heute hier den
Aufbau und auch das Starterkit einfach
für die Größe M hier habt ihr mit dabei
einmal das Nest das ist sozusagen die
Halterung da wo der Grill eben am Ende
mit reinkommt darauf könnt ihr es dann
auch schön verschieben und ihr habt eben
einfach einen festen Stellplatz wo das
drauf stehen kann ihr habt hier den
Konvektor mit dabei damit könnt ihr
nämlich indirekt grillen das heißt der
Grill ist dafür gedacht dass ihr direkt
und indirekt grillen könnt ich habe dir
den Quick Start Guide mit dabei mit
allen wichtigen Informationen einen
ascherschieber hier noch die anzündwürfe
und Grillkohle da ist direkt einfach
schon viereinhalb km dabei und mein
Must-Have und damit ist für mich so das
Starterset ähm vollendet bzw das ist
noch mal optional mit dabei ist einfach
der luftleiter mit dem man den Grill
anzünden kann ich zeige euch das aber
einfach noch mal später ich würde sagen
wir packen jetzt erstmal alles zur Seite
wir bauen das einmal auf und das geht
auch ziemlich einfach
[Musik]
okay das ist echt ziemlich übersichtlich
ich pack mal kurz alles aus und dann
geht's los
[Musik]
ihr achtet einfach nur auf die
Buchstaben denn alles ist hier wirklich
beschriftet und es kann gar nichts
schief gehen also da ist Anleitung lesen
einfach ganz wichtig
[Musik]
jetzt wird das Ei hier reingesetzt und
je nach Größe nehmt ihr euch natürlich
jemanden dazu der euch hilft worauf
Hilfe nur festhalten
[Musik]
das haben wir hier
einfach da oben durch die Öffnung
natürlich darauf achten dass es richtig
rumsteckt und innen damit der Klammer
hier festmachen
und fertig
first step schon mal geschafft mein
Grill steht und ich freue mich richtig
und jetzt zeige ich euch gleich wie
meine anzündet aber jetzt könnt ihr euch
erstmal freuen euer Baby steht
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier die originale
Holzkohle von Big Quinn egg und ich
würde sie euch auch immer empfehlen sie
hat groß und kleines Stücke damit alles
schön gleichmäßig warm wird und lange
warm bleibt das ist eine natürliche
Kohle und was ihr nicht tun solltet ist
Briketts zu verwenden Brennspiritus zu
verwenden denn das setzt sich alles in
der Keramik ab und man braucht halt auch
einfach gar nicht also nehmt einfach
natürliche Holzkohle damit grillt ihr am
besten ihr habt ein super tolles
Ergebnis und vor allem ist es wirklich
so dass gute Grillkohle die man hier
verwendet und vielleicht nicht bis zum
Schluss aufbraucht die könnt ihr später
einfach noch mal weiter verwenden also
da wird auch nichts verschwendet ist
richtig schön sparsam und da spart man
einfach im Endeffekt wirklich mehr Geld
als wenn man irgendwas rein schmeißt was
eben eine Grill am Ende auch kaputt
machen könnte also Holzkohle nehmen die
hat eine super Brenndauer sie heizt
gleichmäßig durch und damit klappt
einfach wirklich wunderbar
dann füllt ihr die jetzt hier praktische
ein bis zum ersten Ring also einfach die
Feuerbox
und wenn ihr jetzt mal reinschaut ihr
habt einfach große oder kleine Stücke
und das ist wirklich perfekt so heizt
sich die Kohle gleichmäßig auf und ihr
habt eine lange Brenndauer also wenn ihr
jetzt nur kleine Stücke hättet das ist
schon mal perfekt und mitgeliefert habt
ihr ein paar Anzündwürfel das sind diese
hier und davon würdet ihr jetzt einfach
nur drei Stück abmachen dann legte
einfach wie so ein kleines Dreieck
einfach oben drauf die müssen auch nicht
unten rein denn das organische Feuer
brennt von oben nach unten und wirklich
ganz wichtig keine anderen Chemikalien
reingeben braucht ihr alles nicht und
sollte auch alles nicht und fürs
herkömmliche Grillen sind drei auch
perfekt denn dann kommt der Grill
wirklich richtig schnell auf Temperatur
falls ihr aber niedrigtemperaturgaren
wollt oder einfach auf einen längeren
Zeitraum ne kleinere Hitze braucht
reicht auch tatsächlich einfach nur
einen anzugreifen da braucht ihr gar
nicht alle drei ich finde die anderen
Würfel super die könnt ihr auch
verwenden allerdings habe ich eine
Alternative die ich noch besser finde
und die zeige ich euch jetzt mal das
hier ist zum Anfeuern mein
Lieblingsspielzeug sieht aus wie ein
Lockenstab ist quasi ähnlich wie ein
Lockenstab solltet ihr nur nicht für die
Locken verwenden sondern zum
anziehensleiter
und zwar bekommt ihr damit den Grill in
unter 10 Minuten auf 200 Grad wenn ihr
sagt ihr wollt eine kleinere Hitze
einfach nur eine Feuerstelle wenn er
sagt ihr wollt schnell auf Hitze kommen
also wirklich in unter 10 Minuten
Aufheizen dann wirklich so wie bei dem
Dreieck eben einfach drei feuerlöstchen
machen
[Musik]
und dann einfach den Deckel verschließen
da heizt jetzt schön von alleine auf
aber dafür muss Sauerstoff rein also
oben öffnen unten öffnen aber hier
aufpassen dass das Netz zu bleibt damit
er einfach keine Kohle rausfallen kann
auf den Boden und jetzt könnt ihr hier
wirklich schön beobachten wie die
Temperatur hoch geht und es geht auch
wirklich richtig schnell innerhalb von
nur wenigen Minuten habt ihr hier
wirklich richtig viel Hitze drauf und
dann solltet ihr auch anfangen das Ganze
zu regulieren das heißt wenn ihr hier
oben und unten die Klappe verschließt
und weniger Sauerstoff reinkommt könnt
ihr wirklich fast gerade genau die
Temperatur regeln und jetzt müsst ihr
einfach nur schauen was wollt ihr denn
Grillen wollt ihr direkt grillen wollt
ihr direkt Rennen wollt ihr was backen
und dafür habt ihr auch hier diesen
Temperatur Guide und könnt wirklich
alles schön nachlesen hier
beispielsweise direkt das Grillen wenn
ihr Gemüse habt Shrimps Fisch Fleisch
ich mache jetzt hier einfach mal so eine
Durchschnittstemperatur von 200 Grad für
normales Fleisch Regel hier oben und
unten das an
und kann dann hier gleich kontrollieren
dass sich die Temperatur einpendelt und
dann hält der Grill auch die Temperatur
Überstunden hinweg viele fragen mich
auch immer wie lange man denn auf dem
Grill grillen kann also es kommt
natürlich drauf an was ihr zubereitet
wenn ihr eine niedrige Temperatur habt
mit der Grillkohle die jetzt drin ist
könnt ihr wirklich über Stunden hinweg
Grillen schmoren die Trick Temperatur
garen wenn ihr so ein herkömmliches
Grill macht wie wir zum Beispiel am
Wochenende es kommt ein bisschen Gemüse
rein Brote werden gebacken es wird
Fleisch gegrillt da sitzen wir doch
schon mal so zwei bis drei Stunden und
können wirklich bei gleich bleibender
Temperatur richtig schön grillen und
oftmals nutzen wir nicht mal die
komplette Grillkohle aus aber das zeige
ich euch später denn man kann die
Grillkohle auch einfach nur ersticken
und beim nächsten Mal einfach wieder
weiter verwenden richtig gut und richtig
Spaß an unser Grill hat jetzt die
perfekte Temperatur wir werden uns jetzt
kulinarischen ein bisschen austoben und
danach zeige ich euch noch wie man den
Grill reinigt denn das ist auch noch
häufig gestellte Frage und falls ihr
Grillrezepte sucht könnt ihr auch direkt
auf piccolate.de schauen oder in meiner
App da gibt's auch genug Rezepte
aber
ich möchte auch noch was zeigen und zwar
ist das die ganzen Grills gezeigt okay
und ich dachte der wäre schon länger
stellen auch aus dem Garten geholt den
habe ich mir hinten irgendwo
so wie soll ich sagen guck mal hier sind
die Grippe weggeschmort weil ich zu
diesem besondere war ja ich habe zu
morax wir brauchen endlich einen zweiten
Grill um Murat sagte Grill ist Grill da
gibt's keine Unterschiede und hat uns
den besorgt als zwischen Kugelgrill kann
man schön zu machen kein offenes Feuer
das Problem war dann aber nur das alles
darauf verbrannt ist man hatte nicht so
wirklich eine tolle Temperaturregelung
ich kann nicht damit klar ich wusste
auch nicht wie man Grill anmacht und
anzündet und wie man mit der Kohle
umgeht und am Ende des Tages weil der
köftespieß mit drauf gepasst hat hat
mein Papa dann auch noch da vorne den
Bereich hier weggeflext damit der
köftespieß drauf passt und man die Köfte
eben schön auf dem Grill oder gibt
darüber und die die Nachbar sind fast an
der Kohlenmonoxid Vergiftung gestorben
das gab es dann auch also wirklich aber
trotzdem ich weiß nicht weg wenn mich
das immer wieder
an damals
[Musik]
brauchen
Anna könnt ihr es später einfach zum
Sperrmüll dazu stellen
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt fertig gegrillt und zwar
auch richtig richtig lecker falls ihr
jetzt noch Grillkohle im Grill habt die
man beim nächsten Mal noch weiter
verwenden kann dann könnt ihr jetzt
gerne die Grillkohle einfach nur
ersticken und zwar einfach zu machen
oben verschließen
unten verschließen dann kommt jetzt kein
Sauerstoff mehr ran der Grill kühlt
langsam ab der hält ja die Hitze
wirklich hervorragend deswegen dauert
jetzt natürlich eine Weile aber wenn der
bei euch so auf der Terrasse im Garten
oder auf dem Balkon steht gar kein
Problem da kommt einfach gar nichts dran
die Grillkohle erstickt und man kann sie
nächstes mal einfach weiter benutzen
falls ihr jetzt keine Grillkohle mehr
hier drinnen habt und alles verglüht ist
macht ihr hier oben und unten einfach
auf und wir nutzen jetzt sozusagen die
pyrolyse-funktion denn jetzt kommt
wirklich ganz viel Sauerstoff rein und
Pyrolyse heißt wir verbrennen hier jetzt
alles an Lebensmittelresten an
Fettresten an Schmutz an Dreck und alles
wird wirklich zu Asche verarbeitet wie
im Backofen wenn Ihr auch eine Pyrolyse
Funktion habt der Grill heizt jetzt hoch
alles verbrennt und am Ende hat man nur
noch ein bisschen Asche die man am Ende
einfach nach hinten kehren kann denn die
Arche jetzt dann noch übrig ist die muss
man nicht entfernen es verbrennt alles
bis zum letzten Rest und tatsächlich bei
uns ist so da muss man einfach gar
nichts entfernen wir schieben das so ein
bisschen nach hinten mit dem Schieber
fertig frische Kohle kommt drauf und das
nächste mal wird weitergeht
falls ihr jetzt hier euer Grillrost noch
sauber machen wollt so wie ich denn ich
habe noch Grillkohle die ich nächstes
mal weiter benutze ansonsten würde ich
es einfach jetzt verbrennen lassen
einmal drüber schrubben fertig dann
nehmt euch einfach hier diese Bürste die
doch hier diesen praktischen Schieber
mit dran und dann könnt ihr hier einfach
alles ein bisschen wegschieben
wegbürsten und fertig
perfekt dann kann ich es jetzt hier zur
Seite stellen und einfach beim nächsten
Mal wieder grillen ganz einfach falls
ihr jetzt doch noch Fragen habt dann
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare
dann beantworte ich sie auch gerne beim
nächsten Mal macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal und tschüss